ما الذي يجب فعله في حديقة الحيوان عندما يكون إنسان الغاب
لديه طفل ولكنه لا يرضع،
أحضر أمًا بشرية مع طفل حديث الولادة لفترة
قصيرة اعرض وأخبر، أعني أنني كنت
على الفور مثل هذا التكريم، كنت بالطبع مثل
كيف يمكنني أن أقول لا لهذا
جلست حارسة الحديقة وايتلي تورنر على
بطانية أمام زوي،
حظيرة إنسان الغاب في حديقة حيوان مترو ريتشموند وهي
ترتدي قميصها العلوي، لا توجد مشكلة، لا ترتدي حيوانات إنسان الغاب القمصان، شرعت وايتلي في إعطاء
زوي الأساسيات التي تشير إلى ثدييها
وتشير إلى ثدييها وتشير إليها
طفل وكونك على هذا النحو يشبه المكان الذي
تحتاج إلى وضعه فيه، لم يكن
طفل زوي الأول، كان هذا
قبل عامين، ويبدو أن زوي ليس لديها
غرائز أمومة بدلاً من احتضان
هذا المولود الجديد، كانت تحمل الطفل
مثل علبة الصودا في بعض الأحيان يجب أن
تضعه  كان على مدير حديقة حيوان ريتشموند،
جيم أدلين، أن يأخذ
الطفل ويربيه لمدة ثمانية أشهر،
واضطررت إلى الانتقال من غرفة نومنا إلى
غرفة نوم أخرى في المنزل لأنني
نمت مع إنسان الغاب فوقي، حتى أنني
أخذته.  ذهبت زوي إلى الكنيسة، لذلك عندما حملت زوي
مرة أخرى، قامت حديقة الحيوان بتركيب
شاشة تلفزيون لتعرض مقاطع فيديو لها عن حيوانات الغابة وهي
ترعى الأطفال الصغار. ارتدى الحراس دمية محشوة
لتوضيح كيف
تحمل الأمهات أطفالهن عادة، لكن التكتيك الذي
قلب مجرى الأمور هو أن وايتلي
أرضعتها بالفعل ثم كانت في الرابعة من عمرها  -
ابن كالب البالغ من العمر شهرًا أمام أعين زوي مباشرةً
وكانت منشغلة جدًا طوال الوقت مثل
مجرد مشاهدتي كما لو كنت
ألقي نظرة خاطفة على كالب
ومشاهدتي، لقد كان الأمر رائعًا حقًا
ونجح في غضون 24 ساعة كانت زوي
ترضع طفلها من أجل  في
المرة الأولى، لا يستطيع شرب عشاءه فحسب، بل
لا يتم حمله مثل علبة
الصودا
CNF New York